agronomist Javier hereda inspects each
Leaf of this lab grown bean plant
he has spent the last four years
studying and nurturing it to save the
species from Extinction
it's a wild variety from Costa Rica
that's at risk of Extinction this is
probably the only remaining specimen in
existence we are regenerating it
simulating its environment these wild
species hold the key to resilience genes
that can offer a solution to water
deficits pests and disease
the seeds of this and tens of thousands
of other native plants are collected
here on the outskirts of Colombia's
third City Cali for the world's largest
tropical seed bank for beans cassava and
animal feed plants called future seeds
in the bank's Laboratories researchers
prepare each seed for storage or
research selecting the optimal ones and
discarding any that are damaged
others work on DNA extraction and Gene
sequencing to decipher and translate the
plant's genetic code of a Global Network
experts say it's vital to breed more
resilient crop varieties at a time when
Food Supplies are increasingly
vulnerable to extreme weather
deforestation and other human activity
so we have two major threats that are
existential one is the genetic erosion
several of these kind of diversity are
disappearing due to urbanization to
roads to to kind of human activity the
second is climate change
the world used to cultivate more than 6
000 different plants but it's estimated
that about 75 percent of crop diversity
has been lost in the last century the
bank hopes to reverse that trend
this airtight package is store more than
60
000 samples of beans and forages and
they're kept here in this huge fridge at
-20 degrees Celsius scientists call it
an insurance for the future here we hold
the seeds that belong the genetic
resources that belong to the countries
of origin we keep them we conserve and
maintain them alive and available also
to the public is
putative solutions to challenges that we
cannot imagine at the moment already
solutions for today's agriculture but
also for the future
thanks to donations the seed bank is
using artificial intelligence to speed
up crop analysis and breathing new more
resistant varieties trying to keep Pace
with an increasingly deteriorating World
Alessandra Al Jazeera Palmira Colombia